okay now this
this uh kind of like a polynomial is
what strain said
it's got a lot of terms in here um 20 of
them actually because you go 20
19 and you count all the way down to one
i would really
not like to have to put into my
calculator all 20 of those terms
if only i had some mechanism for taking
a long string of things that are added
up and then just pop it into a single
formula
oh wait we do because what is this thing
a20
it's a sum of what kind of thing it's a
series of
what form it's a it's a geometric series
because it's the same
ratio being applied over and over again
what is the ratio by the way
1.08 you can see it happening over and
over again okay
so the way that you set this out because
we're kind of making a bit of a leap
here
is to say that this a 20
is a geometry progression with certain
characteristics
right now you may want to if you don't
have it off the top of your head you
want to get the reference sheet out here
but i'm going to write it on the side
here so that we can refer to it we have
a formula
for the sum of the gp and i want to know
what are the things that go into that
formula
because i need to identify them off of
this okay now um
i told her why we actually have two
different formulas
for the sum of a gp which one do you
think might be most appropriate for this
guy
it's the one where the ratio is
bigger than one do you remember that i
mean you could use either you'll get the
same answer either way
but i think the one we're talking about
is this guy
do you agree stay on the referee if you
cannot remember it or hopefully it's
somewhere recently in your notes okay
have a look at that formula with me in
red okay there's three pieces that we
need
to substitute into this what are the
three pieces i need to know what a is
first term i need to know what r the
ratio is which you already told me and
then i need to know
and how many terms are there okay now
i'm going to do something a bit
unusual um i'm going to say a rather
than it being
what i physically wrote first which is
this guy
i'm actually going to say it's this guy
over here
right like i could just write the whole
series in reverse order you'll see in a
second why that's so useful to me i'm
going to say it's 10
000 times 1.08 that's the last one that
i wrote down
the reason why that's useful to me is
now when i write down my common ratio
if i were to go from here forward what
am i doing to get from one term to the
next
what am i doing
hmm am i am i multiplying by 1.08 to get
from here to here
look really carefully i i'm actually see
how 20 goes down to 19
and then it goes down to 18 and so on
i'm actually yeah i'm getting less of
them i'm dividing by 1.08
so if i were to start from here and then
go forward i'd have to say this is
1 over 1.08 oh gross fractions right i
don't do that
so the advantage of starting at the end
is now say well now i'm just going to
multiply
right if i think about starting down
this end and then climbing up it'll go
one two three four et cetera which is
what i want
yeah and that's for all the questions
what you're going to find is for all
superannuation situations
you get this kind of scenario unfolding
right
you're the very first amount that you
put in has the most so chronologically
this one's going to be the biggest right
but for my
purposes it's easier for me to think
mathematically like this
that's a that's r what's n
it's the number of what's the number of
terms which in this case
is the number of years but you've got to
be careful they're not always exactly
the same
if for example put down your pens for a
second because this is
where you have to be very cautious right
look back over at the question over here
okay
suppose i changed the date from 30th of
june
to first of july let's just suppose
that's what i did okay
one day's difference i'm not going to
get the same
i'm not going to get an identical series
to this am i how would it be different
if i went to the first of july
i'd have another 10 000 hanging out here
down the bottom right now do you see
this would actually change right um a
wouldn't be 10 000 times 1.08 anymore
it'd be
10 000 right so this has changed and
then this will also change
right there won't be 20 terms anymore
there will be
an extra one maybe 21 right so just by
changing the day
you can see this has a minor adjustment
to it that will kind of muck with our
answer does that make sense
so be very cautious all right i've got
my a
my r and my n so i can say therefore
a 20 equals and i'm gonna go
for my some of the gp formula we'll jot
it down and then if you haven't already
got your calculator out please
reach for it and let's evaluate it
uh what do i got here here's a
here comes r to the
n minus one
there's r minus one okay so let me pause
there
give the opportunity it is weird but
isn't it so much better than like trying
to do
this um be very careful on your
calculator with your fractions with your
powers
your brackets um it's easy to input this
incorrectly
do you have an answer or a question
let's hold because i think some people
still
get in there just so we didn't spoil it
and you're going to give it to me to the
nearest cent yeah it was a
whole number really
i feel like there should be a decimal
have a close look
well and by the way by the way this is
actually a really good point like where
i
that's looking good where i kind of look
for myself and say is this going to be
reasonable or not
the reason i anticipate a decimal is
because of this do you see this
like oh that's going to be good yeah
so this is going to have weird trailing
decimals on it so that's why it's going
to be melted okay
i feel like enough of you should get
there starts with a four right what is
it four
four nine four five two two thanks rayne
two two nine and give me a number of
cents
21 cents and because we're rounding
you've got to say that you're doing that
so i'll say to the nearest
cent okay
sense check time you always should check
when you can that an answer is sensible
almost five hundred thousand dollars
almost five hundred thousand dollars
does that sound reasonable yeah
yes yeah you're putting in or they're
putting in ten thousand dollars every
year how long they've been doing it for
again
20 years so if we just put ten thousand
dollars under your bed
for 20 years 20 times right that's 200
000
right and you have a big bed presumably
okay building
it's like building so like eight hundred
dollars the first time then on that 800
you get more and then on that more you
get more yeah
uh strength said it exactly right
there's this accumulation effect
so from hundred thousand dollars just
under the bed
it goes to almost half a million because
it has
your first installment which doesn't
start very big right but then by the
time you put the next installment in the
first one is
bigger right because it's been in there
for longer and then by the time you put
the next one in
both of these guys have increased in
size and so you actually have this very
long
i mean this actually looks linear which
is not supposed to be but you're going
to get this
gp that's growing exponentially that's
the whole point behind it
makes sense yes okay i'm going to pause
for a moment because i've been talking
for a long time actually you can see
there's a second
question here and there's only a minor
adjustment it says
how much will the fund amount to by the
end of n
years so we've done it to the end of 20
years right now what i'm going to ask
you
is two things number one um please
answer this question for me
right see if you can come up here's my
expression right here
for after 20 years right i'd like to
modify this and it's only a very minor
modification
to make this any number of views you
like a of n
okay and then could you write this down
for me because i actually am changing
the question that the the textbook had
right
once you've got that once you've
answered part b here's the question i
would like you to answer
how long does it take to get to a
million dollars
this is about half a million right this
is about half a million
i want you to try and work out well how
many years will it take
to get this sum up to a million dollars
can you answer that question for me
so use part b part b will be your
mechanism
to answer that question once you've done
part b see if you can use that to work
out how many years it'll take
to get from here up to a million can you
do that
and then i'm going to write some
assigned questions on the board
a lot of you're at a good spot but then
you've hit a big wall so let me help you
out
i'm interpreting all right so where are
we at just to make sure on the right
page right
what i've written up here is me taking
all of the
pattern establishment that we did to get
to a20
and then say wait a second if i know
what a 20 is which is after 20 years
then if i want it after n years the
particular part of it gets changed
it's not it's not the first term it's
not the ratio those all remain
identical what really changes is how
many terms are in
the series which is this 20 right you
see that so that's why you can see i've
substituted for an
n up there now all i need to do at this
point is just do a bit of tidying up
like it was gross and messy
i could hand this to my calculator
because just numbers
right but but this i cannot because that
end up there i've got to deal with the
premium rule
so hopefully you can see just a bit of
rearrangement i wonder if this aligns
with what you've got
in your working i would highly encourage
you to make sure you actually put these
like entrust as little as you can to
your calculator
because it's dangerous you guys know how
easy it is to put something wrong in
there and then everything else ends up
problematic
so here's my a of n and then i say well
i don't know the whole question is
what value of n will get me two million
dollars
okay so i'm going to try and solve this
here's a
n if it equals did i say a thousand a
million dollars right i want to get to a
million dollars
so now this is the thing i need to solve
right so i want to make in the subject
and now you're realizing i need to call
back on knowledge
from earlier in the year or even last
year right if i divide
through by this 135 000 okay uh what do
we get i think from memory it's like 200
200 i think on 27. something like that
okay i'm trying to
recall me working this out earlier okay
you get this
and then you say i can add one to both
sides that will get me closer to making
n
the subject so that should be like so
okay because the denominator is 27 so i
add 27 to the top but this
at this point you can't get any further
by hand you have to call back the fact
that if this is an exponent right
this is an exponential equation i need
to rephrase it to become a
log equation very good log equations
will change the subject to the exponent
the power
sorry the index is the subject right so
it's going to be log what would be the
base
yeah the base of this is the base of
that that's how i remember it so 1.08
down the bottom
this weird looking fraction is up the
top or maybe you have written in decimal
okay but this i can't put in my
calculator either because my calculator
has two bases
10 and e neither of which is 1.08 so
what do i do here
yeah i need change of base rule right so
it doesn't matter which one you do base
10 or base e
okay um i do base e because i am lazy
and it's easier to write so i'm gonna
have
ln of something divided by ellen or
something else which one's on the top
bottom
carefully 0.818 goes to the top okay now
the way i remember it is the bottom one
goes to the bottom which is actually
easier to do the bottom goes to the
bottom
it does and then the top goes to the top
and this
this we can throw into our calculators
okay
now we're still we're still not out of
the woods yet okay you're going to get
um some number with a lot of decimals
after and i need the decimals this time
it's 20
six five six five give me a few more
okay cool i'm happy with that okay now
at this point
we're with all this process we've been
getting like dollar figures out so we've
been rounding that kind of thing you
know you've got to do some rounding with
this
but you have to be really cautious
you're actually kind of lucky i
could maybe i should have chosen
different numbers here do you want to
say this is if i just round to the
nearest whole number
the nearest whole number is 28 and that
is the number of years because i've got
to get all the way to the end
to get that interest repayment okay but
just put your pens down for a second
look up
suppose our numbers ended up a little
bit different suppose at this point here
instead of getting 27.65
right suppose i got
four 27.45 just suppose right
now this number does not round closest
to twenty eight
okay it rounds closest to 27 rounds down
okay
however even under this circumstance
the answer is still 28.
why what do you think so you haven't
reached a million
at 27. um after 27 years
even though you're actually closer to a
million at this point you haven't got
there yet you're at 999 000 whatever
okay the interest payment hasn't been
made so you're not going to
get it until the end of that year has
elapsed
so it's really important you think
carefully about the situation not just
look at the equations